[Music]
you've probably already heard of Miska
he's kind of a weirdo but he's also one
of the most entertaining people on
Twitch
[Music]
but before mischief was the kind of guy
who would do anything for his viewers he
had to go through a lot with adderall
I'm a God but without adderall I was
nothing I I went to this job it [ __ ]
sucked I woke up in the middle of the
night and I was like coughing up blood
and to get where he is today he almost
had to die first it kind of sounds
really cliche but I kind of followed
what I always wanted to do from my heart
issue which turned me into a streamer
and now I have no heroin oh hey before
we get into the video I just want to
tell you guys that if you like what we
do it's awesome when you leave a comment
but don't forget to sub to the channel
like the video maybe even send us an
email to let us know what you want us to
cover next anyway it's hard to imagine
somebody more suited to being a twist
streamer than biscuit
[Music]
whether he's playing some random game
chatting with his viewers or doing some
IRL stream he always has chat going
crazy
but before miss gif was playing games
and hanging out with huge streamers he
was just like us watching his favorite
streamers hanging out and chat and going
to college in New Jersey I used to watch
a lot of reckful I used to watch reckful
a shit-ton honestly I used to watch a
lot of Mitch - he was going to call it
studying finance got pretty good grades
and even had a job lined up but one of
the biggest investment firms in the
world I was going to work at a company
called Vanguard does anyone here even
know what Vanguard is it's the number
one financial firm in the world of
investments like they have 5.3 trillion
US dollars so I was gonna go work for
them at their flagship program which is
not the easiest thing to get into it was
an amazing opportunity but biscuit
wasn't all that excited about working in
a Feyen guard see he studied finance but
his true love was entertainment I still
want to do something with my life I'm so
young I didn't really know what I wanted
to do but I said to myself it's a good
job I'll live this normal life but I
always said to myself like I'm funny
like I know what my real calling is it's
to be funny I'm a funny guy I'm
entertaining I don't want to live this
life of going to work working eight
hours nine hours they be on adderall for
the rest of my life it just sounds
terrible before he got his new life as a
financial adviser started music if
decided to take a vacation with his
friends what he didn't realize is that
that vacation would change his life
forever I went to sleep that night and I
woke up in the middle of the night I was
like coughing up blood I was screaming
on the top of my lungs and the pain is
described as someone takes a knife stabs
in your heart and slowly twists it I
woke up at like 4:00 in the morning
screaming like crazy my dad was the only
one home because my mom was in Florida
and he just grabs me and just floors it
all the way to the hospital
like floors it after being rushed to the
hospital miss kif was diagnosed with a
heart condition viral myocarditis so
biomarker Dittus I barely even know what
the [ __ ] it is but pretty much what it
is it's a virus that's in my heart
forever and some things can make it come
out where I possibly got it from I don't
know but the only thing I could think of
that I actually it could be you can get
it from anything from sharing with
people and a virus that just goes down
your bloodstream into your heart it's
from what I know
I personally think I got it one time
when I drank pool water at so I would on
the waterslides in Wildwood which is a
place in New Jersey I would go on the
water slides and I would drink pool
water to try to be funny and I think I
when I drank the pool water that night I
started throwing up and that's when I
got sick so I think what happened is I
drank the pool water and there was
probably something in it and I got sick
and then I got my virus so don't drink
the pool water so after all that
mischief was just lying in his hospital
bed he had almost died and it made him
realize that tomorrow
wasn't a guarantee that every single day
could be his last and he didn't want to
spend however many days he had left
doing a job that he hated so he didn't
my friend's dad was in the entertainment
industry where he would build things so
let's say for Blizzcon he would build or
sculpt something and it would go to
Blizzcon ahir that's how he would make
money and he offered me a job in
California to try it out and I said yes
I said all right let's do it so I tried
it I went to I went to this job and it
[ __ ] sucked I got I cried the first
day because the dude yelled at me he
made fun of my heart the entire time he
was a piece of [ __ ] the job was al I
don't live in California by the way when
you're making $40,000 a year you might
as well be homeless because our rent was
$1,400 a [ __ ] month we were living
paycheck to paycheck I barely had money
for food I I couldn't survive out there
on forty thousand dollars we asked for a
raise the guy [ __ ] on me and we I I got
I in the end I quit because I couldn't
afford living there anymore so miss gif
returned home only to find out that his
parents were moving from Jersey to
Florida which meant that he'd have to
pack his bags and move across the
country again but he didn't have one
more chance one more opportunity to get
back into that cushy finance life and as
crazy as this sounds I went back to my
mentor at Vanguard and I'm like dude can
I get the job again he's like sure
somebody okay now I have the job again
after I said no I got the job yet again
for the second time all right
during this time I'm just gonna try
other things and I always wanted to be a
youtuber I always wanted to try youtuber
twitch so I said all right think of an
idea think of a solid idea something
that is new that no one has done before
and something that streamers can react
to so that way they can get views and
that's where I thought of there who is
videos the story of Tyler one is a story
filled with love hate betrayal and
forgiveness what the new influx of
viewers jumping in the Tyler ones
channel wondering who is this guy and
how does he have more viewers than
shroud I thought it would be appropriate
to make a video going over the rise fall
and rise again of Tyler one but once I
robbed watched it on stream and it got a
bunch of likes I think what happened is
people started to share in the
communities and then it started to grow
and then people started to watch the
whole thing and then it just retention
rate was really high of the videos and
it just started to skyrocket so I
started growing really fast on YouTube
like really really fast a lot of people
started reaching out to me and stuff
like that I got a message from ice
beside and this is where things get fun
like most things involving ice misgives
trip was a disaster you come back within
six months you will be arrested and
after that trip miss Ghetts decided to
take an advantage of his fame and start
streaming himself but he had a choice to
make ice wanted me to be his right-hand
man he's like dude you and I could take
over YouTube oh you could be huge on
YouTube I could be huge on YouTube we
can grow together and you'll easily have
a few thousand viewers or you could just
go to twitch and you could just do
whatever and you'll get 50 viewers and
enjoy yourself and I said to myself I
don't ever want to grow or I don't ever
want to be someone's right-hand man I
never want to be someone or grow from
someone because of them I want to grow
because of me missus first dream went
pretty well
but it didn't
I had 300 viewers my first dream like
this is awesome
and we were just [ __ ] around I was
just sitting in the IRL section just
doing whatever I wanted and two days
later I like all right let's play some
World of Warcraft everybody and then
just crickets nobody's there and I went
down the 50 viewers just like I thought
Miz gave tried a whole bunch of stuff in
his early streams he played World of
Warcraft he got into Mario 64 he tried
just chatting of course
holy [ __ ] train wrecks TVs in my street
my stream train wrecks TV that's
twitter.com plus train wrecks TV you
know train wrecks can I go on your
podcast yes mom
but the type of content that resonated
with his fans mode both then and now is
when he collaborated with other
streamers
guess what miss kit if you're gonna get
involved in this business no one's gonna
like you for you not one person I like
you for you
but that's cuz I don't give a [ __ ] about
this right now but maybe when I start
caring I'll use you and then I'll stop
caring about you I'll slam your sister
if you want almost on the desk oh no you
not you of the guy who donate it did
well I'm five five that's perfect
you actually been seriously focus that
you know anyone anyone
did you say you didn't baby [ __ ] oh my
god
misc if slowly grew his stream going
from just a handful of viewers to a few
hundred he wasn't big time or anything
but he was on his way to becoming one of
those streamers that he looked up to I
started growing from other communities
by going on other people's dreams and
farming good ones and as I started doing
that before like wait a minute this guy
actually is funny or this guy can
actually make a joke once in a while or
this guy has a hot sister
and they would start going to my streams
and actually would stay and that's how I
started to grow me escape was basically
streaming full-time now but he still had
one foot in the finance world see he was
still going to school which meant that
that door was always open to him until
in 2019 he closed that door he moved to
Austin and dedicated everything to
screaming because we're like every other
shippers there
why wouldn't we live in Austin I mean
Austin has very cheap real estate cheap
rent it has sodapoppin it has a lot of
other big streamers and it has no income
tax so why not the only problem is that
mischief didn't make the move to Austin
with a bunch of friends he did it alone
I didn't really have any friends here
it's hard to like hang out with people
like when you don't really know them
that well and I didn't no chance I
didn't know Nick that well I didn't know
these people but I knew he Rob very well
and I knew Moxie and what Moxie said
know and didn't hang out with me and
didn't do come down I really didn't need
someone here obstinacy my career and I
will admit that he really helped me out
a lot but he wasn't the only one who
moved into the house
[Music]
means kiss picked up steam fast he got
more and more viewers until you just
couldn't ignore him anymore he was one
of twitches biggest names but he didn't
do it alone he had help from his
roommates his friends and his viewers he
went from an average viewer to one of
the biggest names on Twitch every one of
studs contributed I why do take a lot of
credit for my streaming career I think a
lot of people have helped me and I will
never deny that from ear obtuse uper
cool to jcg to poke 2x you see the Greek
to syn/ack to everyone everyone is help
me
he went from a guy who just couldn't
stop watching twitch streamers to
someone who pulls in almost 8000 viewers
anytime he streams music if made it
he's living every twitch fans dream
every day he streams to thousands of his
fans all of whom love him and he gets to
hang out with the people who used to
look up to and he couldn't be happier
I came to Austin and it really has
changed my life a lot because these
people are my friends and we've gotten
closer and closer and now where have we
hang out all the time there's 10 people
in my house right now
they're all in the living room playing
Super Smash Brothers and that's great
that's what I love I love having people
around
I love having friends I don't have any
people that I could talk to you about my
streaming career and I love having
people around me that or just like to
hang out it's nice yes how I got my in
and what I'm doing an interview get out
now get out now
follow me Michelle
though I said hi Russell I buy it's not
good thing though